ChapGPT最近推出的Image 2.0
好像有點厲害喔
除了繁體中文顯示的很好之外
它的質感就是那種照片的電影感
好像有一點點超越
欸欸 香蕉 你要去哪邊啊?
嗨 我是大友
今天又要來跟大家分享好工具了
自從退訂ChapGPT之後
就很少用它深圖
沒想到它最近居然默默改版了
而且还真是精致,忍不住就玩了一阵子
发现它跟Nano Banana有得比啰
看来又要再次订购它了
当然不只是为了生涂啦
今天我们就来比一比看看
在不同生涂的情境里面
香蕉跟GPT的Image 2.0谁更厉害呢?
今天我会依照下列11个情境来做生成的比较
时间生成的准确性
就先请他帮我生成一张图
然後辦公室後方的時鐘呢
顯示現在是凌晨3點16分
大家真的熬夜感專案的畫面
我們來看看就是他們生成的會如何
欸 生出來了
我們可以看一下這個ChairGPT的畫面
他已經有把這個3點16分盡量標示出來
雖然3應該要在下面點那個時針啦
不過已經算蠻精確了
我覺得還可以
好 我們再來看一下Gemini生成的
欸 這個就很明顯了
我們可以看到後面
明明就是3點16分
可是它的時針還是顯示在三點鐘的位置
所以說GEMINI在生成時間的部分
可能還是沒有辦法那麼的準確
我後來又做了另一個實驗
可以看一下這個是我設定這個
面攤後面的時鐘是顯示12點半
那我這次特別把這個時針跟
分針指的位置都講出來
可是呢還是看得出來
TRAGPT有掌握到這個時針分針的位置
但是GEMINI就沒有囉
產品圖的海報宣傳
首先我們先來看看這隻手錶
我請他幫我生成一個比較科技感
適合上班族的這種廣告海報圖
那ChairGPT幫我生成像這樣子
我覺得還不錯
那German來生成的也OK
只是他的排版我覺得會比較有一點點像簡報
可是也很好看
他們兩個生的這個科技感都不錯
再來我們就生成就是比較
Y2K年輕人音樂流行界的這種海報宣傳圖
那這個ChairGPT生成是這樣
然後German來生成是這樣
GPT本來其實升得還滿有Y2K的感覺
可是中間的手錶就變得有點濕焦了
所以以海報宣傳圖來說
我是覺得GPT有把手錶放大掌握得比較好
那接著我就來試試看用真人生成這種比較有人物的商品宣傳圖
那這邊我是請他幫我生成一個睡眠的噴霧
要高質感像大品牌的廣告那樣
呈現高雅然後細緻的一個畫面
那我們來看一下GPT會把我們生出什麼樣的一個噴霧、睡眠、海報圖呢
欸 已經生成了 我們來放大看一下
嗚 還不錯欸 我覺得蠻好的
而且還有手有噴的那個動作
然後上面顯示著這個字
字型也算是比較細 比較細有質感
產品圖也還OK
我們來看一下GEMINI生成的版本如何
欸 這個GEMINI葉枝尼南伴尼路夢
葉枝尼南 OK
然後他人沒有幫我特別改變 沒有用手拿來噴
所以他有點像合成的 不像真正的海報
左邊比較像真正的海報 右邊就有點像合進去的
所以以海報來說 我可能會選左邊的
一噴入眠整夜好夢 PK 夜之泥南伴你入夢
場景轉換角度的一致性
接著我們就來試試看 就是改變照片的角度
我讓QHGBT呢把這個老爺爺跟馬的照片
變成老爺爺45度的特寫
那右邊的是Banana深層的這個老爺爺特寫
其實兩張深層都跟原本中間那張老爺爺的角度啊
臉啊都蠻像的
細節也蠻清楚
只是右邊那個Banana的馬
這個怎麼輕上去了啊接著我就是看比較遠景的角度看看就是如果拉遠的話兩邊升的效果如何這張看起來是都還可以
只是右邊的版納納變得稍微有點
好像仰角的
就是去俯拍這樣
那接著我們看看側面的
側面的就蠻明顯的
左邊的ChairGPT還是一樣
老爺爺跟馬的位置是相同相對的
右邊的這個馬
比較調皮喔
小爺爺的右手邊了
3D角色的生成
那我給他們指令呢
就是生成一個3D的風格的圖片
那主要就是一個小怪物在上學
周圍就是各種可愛的動物森林
森林動物 然後呢他們給一個
樹爺爺在教課
鏡頭呢從樹爺爺往同學的方向拍攝
然後小怪物呢
主角在中間很認真的做筆記
ChairGPT版本真的滿有電影感的
我覺得而且每個動物的角色種類都不一樣
都不一樣
然後色調就是偏電影的那種比較暗的色調
老爺爺也在前面看得出來是一個樹爺爺
那這個Banana的版本我覺得也很可愛啊
就是很明顯就看得出來是那種3D動畫的那種樣式
只是說後面就有幾個動物它有重複出現了
然後它色調偏的比較亮
前方呢也沒有很明顯看得出來是一個樹爺爺在教課
可是整體我覺得是很可愛
升得很不錯的
這次我請兩個模型升成一個3D的虛擬偶像
我希望它文理清楚
但是還是要看得出來是一個3D的虛擬角色
左邊我覺得就是
大家蠻常看到一些遊戲電玩會看到的樣貌
右邊這個角色
它有刻意幫我把它臉部的
這個一點點的雀斑跟很像皮膚的狀況秀出來
我覺得如果以我的需求來說
右邊是比較符合
就是再多一點文理的觸感
因為左邊太光滑了
所以如果你想要用自己的圖片
來生成一些不同的造型的話
目前我想應該是缺GVT會把你皮膚生的好一點
模擬真實的照片
這邊我就請他幫我生成一張
就是在街上自拍的一個亞洲的女生
然後直視的
可以看得出來
這個缺GVT跟JAMIN都已經生成了
那我們來比較一下兩個的生成效果
左邊確實就是有一種
用手機拿著自拍的那個自拍的照片
那右邊他可能理解成
我希望有一個圖是有一個女生拿著手機在自拍
所以對於這個指令理解度來說
我覺得左邊比較符合我的需求
就是我是要一個自拍照的樣子
接下來呢我們就用照片來合成看看手機自拍效果
我是跟他說就是用這個人呢
高空彈跳的時候自拍的樣子
左邊我覺得是蠻真實的啦很驚訝
右邊的是誰
所以我不信我就再生成一個
在纽约街头自拍的Y2K青少年的照片
我觉得其实这张右边的这个造型比较真实一点
可是左边的是比较像我
这个案例
两个都不算成功
模拟手写字的真实感
这边我就请他帮我生成一个关于生物学细胞分裂的这个学生的笔记
那笔记是用原子笔书写的
然后字机呢是很流畅
还有一些彩色笔画的这个重点
然後呢如果有一些付出的話
他可以用一些像是圖片啊
或剪貼式的這種報紙黏上去
誒生成出來我們來看一下
確居替身的我覺得還蠻真實的
放大看
這根本就是那種小時候功課很好的同學
做出來的筆記本的樣子嘛
你看那個字
有沒有
你有沒有同學也是這種字體的
就是字很好看然後寫得很整齊這樣
畫圖啊一些插圖啊
細胞膜的那個裡裡外外的樣子
嗯這個真的不錯
那我們接著來看看JAMMY來生成的版本
放大一看呢
嗯
寫得也蠻整齊的啦
畫得也還不錯
只是就有一點點像某一種電腦的字體打出來的樣子
接下來是一個模仿老奶奶學會寫字之後
把自己一生記錄下來的這個手寫字的樣子
1945年戰爭結束了我們回到家房子壞了田地也罷了80歲我去上學了
我鼓起勇氣報名
一輩子沒上過學
現在終於要學會寫字了
欸?看到這個JAMIN NIGHT
深沉了感覺又回到現實了
結果這個字體又是太可愛
很大
好像不是奶奶寫出來的字的樣子
雖然剛才那個也有點太漂亮了吧
軟體介面模擬
這回合我們來請他生成這個YouTube螢幕截圖的畫面
看看他是不是可以真實的呈現我們現在平常在看網頁的時候
接下來的那個樣子
那我這邊是請他生成一個阿姆斯撞登錄月球的紀錄片
欸不行啊 因為可能有一些名人在裡面所以他不讓我生成
結果Gaminar反而可以了
生起來還不錯
只是Gaminar右下角這個留言的區域好像跟我們平常看到留言的位置不太一樣
位置不太一樣
那我就請他生成另一個白皈蛤蜊的這個做法的影片好了
因為這應該比較常見啦 比較沒關係
好 那結果呢 我們來看一下
GPT已經幫我們生成了
而且還幫我們生成了兩種版本
左邊黑色 右邊白色的
我們先來看一下黑色的
放大看一下
這個真的就
蠻像我們平常在看YouTube的時候
右邊有一個播放清單
然後下面有留言
中間就是一般YouTube的介面這樣
白色看得更清楚
好像有進到某個人頻道
然後看一下他的整體的視覺
還有真實網友留言的內容
什麼
跟著Amy做了好幾次了
家人都超愛
那我們再來看看Gamilat生成的版本
Gamilat生的版本就
一樣就是右下角多了一個字創的留言區
那整體其實
介面是沒錯可是
就會發現他的字體感覺就很像key上去的
不像是真正原本就在網頁裡的那種原生的字
那接着我们来看看它生成的这种Premiere剪接软体的界面
会不会长得很真实
这个是ChairGT的版本
看起来就平常我们剪辑的轨道啊
然后左边有一些工具
那这边呢是Gamini生成的版本
这个生的我觉得
蛮像我现在正在剪辑的画面
给各位看一下我现在真实剪辑的样子
真的是长得很像
多个物件的组合图
我就将这个含有很多物品衣服啊装饰的这个图
請他合成 讓這個人穿著全部的東西在一個空間裡
看他生成的自不自然
那我就先丟給HGPT請他生成一下
欸 生出來了 我們來看一下他生成的效果如何呢
放大來看
有帶這個墨鏡 然後背著這個包包 帶著手錶 相機也有
白色T恤 藍色女仔褲 跟內雙白色鞋子
整體都還算OK 只是
他把有些物件還是重複擺放在桌子上啦 這個我覺得就不需要
我們來看一下 Gemini的版本
嗯...就...感覺這個人土土的喔
就...全部的東西都擺放的沒有錯
都有出現在畫面裡了
但唯一好看的好像只有後面那個工作室的場景
接下來我來試試看網路上流行的這個換髮型的參考指南
那我就是給他一個照片加上九宮格的這個不同髮型的這個髮型參考圖
請他幫我套用一下
結果GPT就幫我生成了這樣子一個髮型參考書了
我們來看一下如果放大看的話
就可以看看自己如果留不同髮型會長什麼樣子
我覺得這個還蠻有點像的
因為有些髮型好像真的留過
可以拿來當作一個參考啦
那我們來看一下 Gemini
一樣的髮型也一樣的人
一樣的指令他會生成什麼樣的東西給我
嗯?
這是一個什麼連連看嗎?
每個人都長得不太一樣
這真的是我自己嗎?
而且還有重複的
我們先對比一下原本是這樣子
我是要這幾個髮型
然後我們再看一下他生給我什麼東西
整個版面都有種敷衍我的樣子
可能是絕本來累了
YT縮圖的生成這次我來試試看拉一個圖片照片給他然後請他生成一張主題就是最新版本ChairGPT Image 2.0的生成效果
而且要吸引人像是爆款影片那樣的一個YT縮圖
我們來看看他生成的效果如何
好,Image 2.0已經生出來了,我們來看一下
欸,蠻吸睛的耶
我覺得
這個很像我某一張影片的縮圖
除了那個邊框有點螢光綠怪怪的
但是整體確實是重點都有出來
然後還搭配相關的圖文
我們再來看一下Germini的版本
Germini生的也OK 只是長得有點不像我
然後整個的畫面也很乾淨
只是衝擊感
QAGBT我覺得再多一點
我又試了不同主題 就是夏天捍衛來襲的主題
討論一下這個臭味的部分
QAGBT這張生的我覺得非常的棒
接下來呢 Gemini生的這個其實也不錯
只是他的色調有點可能就是要讓人感覺臭臭的
所以他的色調就綠綠橘橘的
兩個人表現都不錯啦我覺得這回合
哪個你會想點下去呢留言跟我說
角色動畫分鏡圖的生成
接下來我給他幾個關鍵的畫面
請他幫我生成10個連續的這個分鏡圖
展示這個角色呢在被大金剛追逐之後的完整場景
要包含场景编号跟制作的笔记
就是说每一幕它到底是什么主题
然后简单的描述这样子
好GPT生出来了我们看一下
生得很好耶
你看它编号很清楚
然后每一个画面它都帮它落一个主题
对于这个基础的影片拍摄参考
还蛮有帮助的
而且下面它又说明了有关色调
跟整体影片的调性
German来生的这个版本就是英文版的
我不知道为什么不是生成中文版的
他也有將每一個畫面延伸的故事幫我畫出來
接著我就用開頭那個一開始生的這個
麵攤老闆的照片
請他幫我為這個角色生成一個一系列十個畫面的故事
我覺得這個生的也很好
你看最後燈火熄滅的麵攤
然後老闆獨自在這邊休息喝茶的樣子
Jimman這個部分呢其實他分鏡是畫得蠻不錯的
只是我不知道為什麼我給他真實照片他生成這種比較繪圖的版本
再生成一次他還是給我這種線條卡通版
但是畫得很好 而且他特別喜歡小黃瓜跟豆干 他幫他彩色的
食譜文字的版面生成
這是我請他幫我生成義大利海鮮燉飯的那個烹調過程的教學啦
我們來看一下GBT生成的版本呢
很清楚左邊有大圖沒錯 然後右邊也依照這個步驟
切分了幾個版面區塊
那我們放大來看
字的部分其實因為它字太多了
所以還是有一些看不清楚的地方
像這個我圈起來的地方就
什麼分次加彌敦除
GEMINA就給我這種比較
繪圖的版本
也是版面左邊有大圖
右邊有區塊很完整
但是放大來看一樣就是它的這些字
什麼丁極撈蔥未算
兩個在小字的表現上
都有可能是會有出錯的機率啦
看那個2.0
因為它的字真的很有氣質
比Ned Banana的
我覺得是真的有粗暴跟細緻的差別